like there's so many activities that i
like the idea of you know like like i
like the idea of camping
you know i mean the idea two days two
days
the idea sounds cool until you [ __ ]
wake up and it's
like the [ __ ] worst thing i hate is
when you wake up and everything's just
damp you feel things and it's just damp
and damp is like
the worst [ __ ] climate you know what
i mean it's it's like
everything's damp and moist and i'm
depressed and it's cloudy and i'm just
like why am i here
i chose to be here this is supposed to
be relaxing i did then you should come
camping in australia man it's like
it's like [ __ ] drier yeah but then
everyone everything wants to [ __ ]
kill you and i have something else to
worry about
only if you go out and [ __ ] with the
animals don't [ __ ] with the animals and
they'll leave you alone because camping
in the uk is just either [ __ ] coalish
[ __ ] or just not gonna lie in the uk
sounds [ __ ] horrible
right i mean because we have to do a
thing in the uk called like oh you don't
have to do it it's optional duke of
edinburgh did you do that
my sister did that yeah well you
basically like have to do a bunch of
things to get a
a [ __ ] like go out camping yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and
they always told you in school it's like
you should get it because it's going to
look amazing when you apply for jobs and
no no one can't no one cares and on it
like yeah you have to do like a hiking
slash camping thing where you
uh do two days of like full hiking with
like the big bags
yeah and then camp and i this this is
gonna
sound like so [ __ ] stupid but i was
the only one who was like i'm bringing a
pillow
i want to be comfortable when i sleep
the privileged white boy
i don't know so i i big brained it right
because all these kids brought like dumb
[ __ ] right and and
we had to we brought like a stove to
cook on as well yeah like 16 as well so
i brought the pillow right and as i was
sleeping they all start [ __ ] trying
to take it from me in this tent
because i because they were sleeping on
the hard floor rolled up and i'm like no
no no no
i'm the one who was the stupid dick who
carried this pillow
all the way for like eight hours this is
my pillow this is my reward
and i woke up and one of them had
[ __ ] took it and i woke up on the
thing
covered in [ __ ] dampness and i was
like oh my god did it rain bear in mind
this is the three-person tent
yeah four of us in it and i woke up
being like oh my god it must have rained
so much i go outside it's completely dry
right and i'm like oh it was sweat it
was all sweat it was all condensation
ah yeah because my sister did duke of
edinburgh but she did like the highest
level so she like
it's like it's like a week right yeah
she hiked across vietnam twice
what yeah yeah why would you why would
you want to do that i don't know
i did it twice though i did two days and
i was like i think no this isn't for me
i
i i'm gonna go back to sitting on the
bed
i think that i just said this isn't for
me
why why did you even like decide to do
it well because it's one of those things
where it's like
i can do it yeah if you ask me to go
hiking for a week i'll do it i'm very
capable of doing it right yeah i just
hate every second of it well then why do
you accept it
my parents were like you should do it
and i was like fine okay okay
and i was doing the other stuff anyway
because i was i was teaching kids chess
at my old school yeah uh i don't know
man like i knew from the get-go when
like the the
option was brought up of would you like
to do duke of edinburgh like would you
like to go hiking
and [ __ ] experience dampness for a
week straight i was like yeah
of course they don't i think because as
well they wanted like the kids who had a
lot of experience
camping to help the kids who hadn't done
any
and i was only like there was only like
three or four boys and like the boy
scouts in like my year and then there
was like me who done a lot of camping
so it was like okay so you were the
experience i guess yeah to me it was
like connor should help out and you're
the boy scout
you know i never did anything like map
direction or anything like that i used
some
my parents [ __ ] did all that yeah i
might barely help with setting up the
tents yeah
like you just put the bag down i used to
be like i'm gonna play with the frisbee
so when we did it i do remember this as
well like when it came i was like i'll
i'll do the cooking you could you can
set up the tent because
and because it was one of the cheap ones
as well the cheap ones are like
connect the 576 poles together and it's
like no
none of them can get it right and i'm
like i'm going to cook the bacon that i
brought
yeah i was yeah i i i i've been down to
go camping though in japan i've never
been camping in japan
we should do glamping yeah ramping is
cool i've never gone i've never it's
like camping without all the
frustrations
it's like camping with privilege it's
like compelling with
civilization like if we didn't if we
didn't want to like
invent all this [ __ ] we wouldn't have
been it
might be real i don't want to camp
without 4g like what's the point i'm
just going to say it right
i know it's not the same i don't give a
[ __ ] i want 4g i can count without 4g
i can count with that okay you know you
know what you know what i need a toilet
you're right toilets yeah
i i i don't want a [ __ ] in a [ __ ] bag
or a hole in the ground
with there's a reason there's a reason
[ __ ] humans evolved
and invented toilets in civilization
have you ever wiped your ass with a leaf
no it just doesn't work you but that's
all you have
what are you gonna do grab a handful of
grass no you have to use leaves and hope
you can just get most of it out it's
awful
well that's why like the one thing we
always took camping was a like a bunch
of toilet rolls
damn dude 20 20 man yeah yeah because
what you just you go out into the bush
you'd wipe yourself i'll put it in a bag
and then you throw all that
i must have been as like 12 year old me
it was like instant noodles or toilet
roll
[ __ ] dude i can't eat the toilet
chicken flavor though come on
chicken flavor or poopy butt like oh god
it was i do remember when we did it
there was awful because like it was a
lot of kids that were
just not prepared at all yeah and had
never even done any hiking at all right
and
those those things are heavy yeah yeah
and a lot of them just couldn't do it
and you had to stay as a team
so it's like every 15 minutes one kid
would have a [ __ ] mental breakdown
yeah and it was like i can't do it i
can't hold it
i have nothing to say so the only thing
that like puts me off camping in japan
from what i've seen
like only only like the pictures and
everything i've seen is that it looks
very how can i say it's commercialized
because it's it's like you you have this
like camping sport and like i see a
bunch of tents there it's very
privileged yeah yeah and i'm just
like you're put right next to someone
yeah yeah and it's just
i remember the one thing um i remember
about camping it's just like
how little noise protection you have
from one tent to another right oh you
hear
everything yeah right and especially
the what i've you know especially the
camping experience i would like to have
which is like
a bonding mate like i don't know
especially if you have like a bunch of
japanese people around you with tens and
everyone values that privacy can you
imagine how
quiet you'd have to be oh we could just
be those like ignorant gaijin just be
like
no one's making noise at this campsite
well i think we will like [ __ ] it
what are they gonna say you just hit
like 2 am just like aggressive uno
noises
like from drunk people
[ __ ] jojo uno session at two in the
morning in a tent should do trash taste
hiking special
oh i'd be down man i used to go hiking
all the [ __ ] time
actually that's that's the only thing
the other worst part is it's actually
not a bad idea
yeah yeah i'd be down there i'd be down
you know it's
it's all about i'd be willing to do it
now is it for content okay
i'm willing to [ __ ] suffer for
content whatever
[Laughter]
i am i am i am that's that's that's the
tipping point right at least like
i'll do it but is it monetized
yeah all right i'll do it